the Joe Rogan experience when when I was
in Africa you reminded me they eat a lot
of blueberries and so these colored
foods are also good to eat so
resveratrol comes on when yams dark
things right well yeah leafy visuals but
also fruits that are very colored
colorful so why why is that why is a
well I'm glad you asked the so we have
this idea called Zener hormesis and it's
a terrible name for something that's
quite simple and that is that these
molecules from plants are produced to
make the plants healthier these are
stress response chemicals and if you
stress plants they turn colored turn on
a UV lamp or put a plant in a Sun it'll
turn reddish you know mm-hmm those are
stressful chemicals to survive and I
believe that we've evolved to sense
those chemicals in our food supply
oh so we're attracted to juicy red
tomatoes or as opposed to pale Tomatoes
was just a flavor to it
I think we're attracted to it because
they're colorful but what our bodies get
out of it is that these chemicals go
into our bloodstream and they turn on
our defenses against disease to survive
why is that good why did that evolve or
potentially evolve it's I think because
when our food supply was stressed we
need to get ready for adversity because
we probably run out of food and if
you're a bird or some other dumb animal
dumb or animal or even a yeast cell how
you gonna know if your food supply is
gonna run out you've got it know it
chemically
so these chemicals are a heads-up that
adversity is coming so if you eat a lot
of these chemicals through say red wine
which is stressed grapes and other
things like that blueberries these
chemicals they're not probably not
working mainly through antioxidant
activity they're giving us this stress
heads-up
isn't there there's that's a
controversial thing the red wine thing
correct like whether or not red wine the
the actual compound of resveratrol is
where we're getting our benefit from
because it's apparently a very small
amount of resveratrol and what red wine
yeah sure it's not really controversial
except when people exaggerate and say
that it's all resveratrol resveratrol is
a component of dozens of healthy
molecules in red wine
quercetin which is
for a number of things there's a whole
bunch of polyphenols they called and so
resveratrol is part of that cocktail was
a fermentation process because we're
talking about grapes themselves with the
high sugar content actually being
something we should avoid right so don't
eat the grapes but but wine if you don't
have too much of it will have a
concentrated amount of these xeno
hermetic molecules like resveratrol and
corseted this is apparent in red wine
it's really only in red wine white wine
is just for chicks right not as healthy
actually that's right that's a joke for
my friend bud yeah you'll get in trouble
everyone know it's just for my friend
bud
he loves white wine I'm like that's for
chicks bro I'm joking folks just jokes
don't get it touchy yeah so you don't
need to so that when we treated mice
with resveratrol they were immune to the
effect of high-fat diet
Western diet and we've traced this down
to a single genetic pathway that we work
on these sirtuins I talked about these
nad responsive pathways really so they
were immune to eating shitty food like
the negative aspects of eating shitty
food yeah that this was 2003 that's why
it hit all the newspapers because it was
the first molecule that was safe and
could mimic the effects of fasting or
caloric restriction without actually
having to be hungry Wow and what kind of
dose are you giving these mice it was
the equivalent of about 250 milligrams a
day in a human okay so is 1/4 of what
you recommend people take right I don't
recommend people take anything but okay
what you take right let's just say that
yeah I don't recommendation sorry folks
yeah I'm taking a higher dose because
I've looked at human clinical data and I
think that a higher dose may be required
to have an even better effect on
longevity but the results are very clear
when we opened up these mice maybe I
shouldn't have said that when we
examined those mice carefully put them
to put them to sleep for scientific
purposes it was clear that they they
were healthier now they were still fat
that was interesting there was still fat
so we figured the experiment didn't work
but their arteries were
their livers were like a healthy lean
young Mouse and when we looked at their
metabolism it was like a younger Mouse